debout à l'autre du pays des initiatives
ont été mis sur pied pour sensibiliser
les jeunes au phénomène de la
désinformation
mais aux yeux de bien des experts les
lacunes elle se trouve dans nos écoles
à défaut d'avoir au programme un cours
consacrés à l'éducation aux médias
c'est à l'initiative des enseignants que
cette matière est apporté une école
secondaire de l'ouest de montréal
nous avons ouvert ses portes pour qu'on
puisse voir de près comment tu es si
près pourquoi finalement on parle de
désinformation
comment est née l'idée de faire ce
projet en particulier l'idée provient
principalement de tout ce qui se déroule
en rien que l'actualité avec qui allie
la désinformation qu'on va retrouver sur
médiatique puis le l'intention c'était
d'outils les jeunes se repérer à travers
tout sauf pour développer leur esprit
critique le démystifier cette grippe ce
qui peut s'y trompa rossi à la fois ci
nous ont fait le vaccin qui a su le
médecin puis on est en train de voir si
c'est possible
comment vouliez venu et comment voulez
bien au premier éternuement premiers
mois ce que je fais maintenant c'est que
je sais déjà c'est de voir si le vaccin
et c'est possible que ça va attaquer le
corps ouais et de ce que je vois c'est
parlant pour sa part à lui dit cette
attention et les médias si dangereux
mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire que
c'est dangereux
en particulier le long après j'ai
concret qui nous explique comment est ce
que ça peut être dangereux dans un non
sens on voit les outils comme citoyen
exactement puis ils vont être beaucoup
plus informés break mieux informer aussi
puis vont était aussi plus compétents
dans la manière de naviguer sur internet
ce qui est super important aujourd'hui
parce qu'on le sait mais qu'est ce qui
s'est passé l'équipe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi le risque si les gens sont
plus capables d'identifier ce qui est
beau tout ce qui est faux ce qui est
vrai cette désinformation en général ça
fait que les gens aient pris les
mauvaises décisions et pas dans des
situations sont épatants arrêtant des
élections ce que je vivais rite ex bar
lausanne berytech ce qui est un peu un
call que des décrypteurs
[Musique]
mais l'objectif ultime qu'est ce que
vous vous entrevoyez de toute évidence
en fait l'intention de ça c'est que
l'élève soit au centre de ce projet là
en 2019 ont conclu qu on france dans la
langue depuis 2016 et 10 portant un
petit fils à maintes reprise les
complots et produit des idées propres à
l'extrême droite
enfin le journal difficile de
l'information incohérente
à propos de la pandémie du coc u19
chaque élève a été amené à s'occuper
d'une tâche différente à l'intérieur de
ce projet là donc la création du djing
or la création du logo la création de
sites internet et toutes les plateformes
qui vont être en lien avec le projet
d'airé texte aujourd'hui nous allons
vous présenter une bonne des fossés
convention qui a été propagée sous les 2
au 6 août
il s'agit du trouvère la santé de la
flore et de 56 ans georges marco y avait
un contexte contre la kabylie défense
est définie par personne on peut de
prendre la cause du tort que ça après
coup là et quel point les instances
publiques devrait mettre un peu plus
d'emphase de ressources et de moigné
pour word surgir le projet solo en
espérant que ce petit projet de soin la
boule de neige qui amène l'avalanche
dans les autres écoles
est-ce qu'on est tellement soumis à
différents types d'informations qu'on a
des difficultés elle démystifie le vrai
du faux
alors en mettant de l'avant de ce type
de projet là ça va permettre justement à
l'élève de lui donner des ressources
pour pouvoir naviguer adéquatement sur
internet surtout avec efficacité qui va
lui permettre de développer son esprit
critique qui toujours à la clé de ce
type de projet là c'est vous permettre
davantage conscients inconscient
au début on pense à huy les fausses
nouvelles le continuer à travailler qui
aurait cherché ces groupes sont partout
on est plus portée a vraiment cherché si
c'est vrai ou faux qu'avant avant je
pense qu'on croyait plus qu'est ce qu'on
voyait sur les réseaux sociaux que pour
vous en tant qu'étudiant en tant que
citoyen parce que surtout une autre
génération née beaucoup sur les réseaux
sociaux ils sont habitués mais ça ne
s'apprend pas vraiment un pauvre croire
tout ce qu'on dit y'a pas plus attention
et adultes avec lesquels je parle qui
viennent me voir comme tisseur gars que
j'ai vu sur facebook puis tu regardes tu
vois tout de suite que ça aucun sens
vous voyez déjà des résultats concrets
je vois que mon projet fonctionne bien
que j'ai réussi à attiser le doute chez
eux et l'esprit des réflexions si le
doute raisonnable
cet effet
jeff on voit comment dans les écoles
tranquillement il ya des enseignants qui
qui prennent les devants avec leurs
propres terres leurs propres moyens pour
enseigner la lutte à la désinformation
qu'est-ce que tu conseillerais à une loi
un enseignant qui veut se lancer nos
jardins l'initiative démarche-là web un
jeu juste commencé par saluer les
preuves qu'ils font c'est vraiment
excellent comme initiative
malheureusement nos pauvres et manquent
d'éducation mais dire systématique au
québec se passait quelque chose qui est
important parler des gens ces angelots
jeunes c'est quelque chose de
fondamental auquel j'ai aidé à mettre
sur pied le programme 30 secondes avant
d'y croire de la fpjq de la fédération
professionnelle des journalistes du
québec qui organise des visites de
journalistes dans les écoles on sait
franchir justement comment parler aux
jeunes qu'on s'est rendu compte c'est
que ils n'ont pas la même vision de
l'information que nous vous quand on
leur demande qui s'y est déjà lu un
journal et pour tous les grands monts si
on prend cette approche le pont se met à
parler de des médias traditionnels dans
ce cas là ça peut être un peu difficile
pour eux de comprendre parce que c'est
pas dans le respect des règles au
système d'information en revanche ce
qu'on a remarqué c'est que les jeunes
comprennent très bien les réseaux
sociaux c'est leur environnement donc
c'est une façon de pouvoir aller les
chercher de parler leur langage peut
dire de regarder quand vous voyez une
publication sur les réseaux sociaux qui
a vu plein de gens plein de commentaires
ça peut avoir l'air plus fiable parce
que beaucoup de gens ont participé ont
cliqué dessus mais c'est pas
nécessairement le cas parce que ça peut
être manipulée que ces choses-là piscine
comprennent mais des choses qu'ils
comprennent - dans la façon dont la
désinformation super c'est là où on peut
donner des trucs des outils faciles à
cesser leur manque de familiarité avec
les médias traditionnels
c'est là que ça vient un peu joué parce
que pour eux les médias c'est des sites
web donc certainement avoir entendu
parler des grandes marques au québec
le journal à montréal je pense que tout
le monde connaissait radio-canada aussi
ses démarches
quand même très connu mais n'ayant pas
tenu un journal dans les mains n'ayant
pas forcément regarder en bulletins de
nouvelles à la télévision
c'est un peu comme si tu comparais en
site web un autre donc un site web qui
contiennent l'information ou compromis
ou de essayé bien monter le site web ça
peut avoir dans leur équivalent au site
web du journal à montréal au delà price
par exemple donc c'est vraiment
désensibiliser à comment les gens ont
obtenu cette information le comment le
travail de journaliste se fait et ça
c'est quelque chose d extrêmement
méconnu par je suis auprès des jeunes
auprès de la population générale
ainsi c'est quoi le processus
journalistique comme on trouve
d'information la différence entre des
chroniques d'opinion des articles aussi
dans les journaux c'est la tête de la
section opinion qui se séparent âgées
des otages s'est libéré opinions ou des
baous idées dans un fil facebook c'est
n'y a pas de libérer donc non pas
comprendre ces enjeux là c'est super
important
ouais c'est ça l'éducation aux médias un
film mais justement je pense que ça
serait bon pour la population générale
de mieux connaître le travail des
journalistes auprès des gens est encore
plus crucial parce qu'ils commencent
leur vie citoyenne leur vie citoyenne
puis leur vie numérique ou s'ils sont
plongés dans un chaos sur les réseaux
sociaux où toutes les sources
d'information sont présentés de façon
équivalente donc c'est encore plus
important de leur inculquer ce niveau